once again the wire team has overcome
fear and loathing to journey to las
vegas for CES behind me is the
convention center where there are
thousands of vendors showing literally
tens of thousands of products now this
year unlike past years there's no really
break out gee whiz gadget that you've
got to have instead there's a lot of
incremental upgrades one of the big
areas that we're looking at is tablets
there's going to be a lot of competition
for the iPad this year from the likes of
Motorola lenovo even vizio the guys who
make cheap flat screen TVs have their
own tablet and google's planning a new
version of android they call it
honeycomb which is meant for tablets now
are these tablets going to be
competitive with the current market
leader the iPad it's too soon to say but
we're really looking forward to more
competition in the tablet space for
smartphones the news is all about geeky
upgrades we're talking dual-core
processors more memory giant four and a
half inch screens if you're the kind of
person who likes to geek out about how
fast your CPU is or how much RAM your pc
has you're going to be a happy
smartphone shopper this year all the
major consumer electronics manufacturers
are here of course so we're going to see
lots and lots of car audio equipment
stereos cameras and of course lots and
lots of TVs the one thing you can count
on is that it's all going to be bigger
brighter faster and hopefully better